Parliament special committee on tax
rulings for favored multinationals
advance its investigation with firsthand
evidence from expert witnesses including
the man who set the ball rolling
luxembourg whistleblower anh tuan dealt
or gfinity clovis come ova des hommes
continue our village at unpleasant I
pleasures Becker could even more example
air it happened stood out tour is facing
criminal proceedings over his
disclosures of the tax deals given to
multinationals in luxembourg a practice
seen in other member states such as
ireland belgium and the netherlands from
which the committee has just returned
the rule of the game is let's compete to
attract dinkum for multinationals
citizens cannot stand is mario monti
former EU Tax Commissioner also appeared
offering sound if dispiriting insight
taxation is firmly seated in the kingdom
of unanimity so it's all too easy for
each member state to block anything
notably absent from the hearing any of
the several multinationals invited to
attend any Peas hope they won't refuse a
second invitation scheduled for later
this month
all right